bonjour je suis Bernard pic je suis le
directeur adjoint des essais de la
certification du
[Musique]
hlene c'est un établissement public un
acteur public qui depuis plus de 120 ans
accompagnent les acteurs privés et
publics dans leur démarche d'innovation
et accompagne les industriels lors du
développement de leur produits vis-à-vis
du marque H et la mise sur le marché
dans le cadre de nos investissement et
de nos développements nous avons eu le
plaisir d'inaugurer le 19 décembre 2023
un tout nouvel équipement le le nouveau
laboratoire de
[Musique]
radiofréquence alors ce projet il a deux
raisons tout d'abord il y a de plus en
plus de modules de communication
connectés qui sont intégrés dans les
produits industriels il y a une forte
croissance lorsqu'on regarde les les les
données quantitatives on peut estimer
que d'ici 2025 on aura un peu plus de 21
milliards d'objets connectés dans le
monde et donc il y a une nécessité
derrière cela de pouvoir tester et
évaluer ces produits à la fois en terme
de performance de robustesse et de
sécurité la deuxième raison aussi de cet
investissement c'est qu'on a un contexte
réglementaire évolutif et assez
contraignant tous ces produits connectés
sont soumis à une directive la directive
raid qui s'applique avant la mise sur le
marché de ces produits connectés pour
obtenir le marquage CE et permettre aux
industriels de pouvoir vendre ses
produits sur le marché
[Musique]
européen
nous avons souhaité collaborer avec no
qui est une société d'ingénierie dans le
domaine de
l'électromagnétisme et qui a des
activités orthogonales et
complémentaires à celle du LNE ils
interviennent beaucoup plus en phase
amont de la conception des produits
alors que nous LNE nous allons
intervenir et accompagner les
industriels sur la mise sur le marché
avec des tests de performance et et de
d'évaluation de robustesse et avec
également une ambition commune pour
Nexio et LNE de développer et de mettre
en œuvre cette plateforme de laboratoire
en
[Musique]
radiofréquence je m'appelle Arna Fayette
je suis responsable technique radio Olne
depuis maintenant 2
ans donc ici on est dans une chambre
chamb semi-anécoïque à 3 m donc
semi-anécoïque pourquoi parce qu'il y a
un plan de masse réfléchissant au sol
donc cette chambre c'est une cage de
phadé donc l'extérieur est entièrement
métallisé de façon à ce que les ondes ne
rentrent pas à l'intérieur de l'enceinte
tout autour on a mis des tuiles de férit
on en a 20000 ils ont tous été fixés à
la main un à un sur ces tuiles de férite
on est venu rajouter des absorbants donc
les tuiles comme les absorbants ont pour
rôle de faire en sorte que les ondes ne
se réfléchissent pas à l'intérieur de la
salle de façon à ce qu'on pu mesurer ce
qui provient du produit donc l'idée ici
c'est de disposer le produit sous test
donc là on peut avoir des produits qui
font à peu près 2 m de haut par 2 m de
large jusqu'à à peu près une tonne et on
les met en place sur ce plateau tournant
et en face on a un M d'antenne qui peut
aller de 1 m à 4 m et sur lequel on va
venir connecter les différentes antennes
en fonction des bandes de fréquence
qu'on va venir
regarder
[Musique]
pour nous au LNE ce laboratoire il vient
compléter l'offre globale dont on
dispose on fait déjà au LNE la CEM dans
deux autres cage on fait également la
sécurité électrique pour les produits
industriels et médicaux et donc pour
répondre à l'ensemble des exigences
essentielles il nous manquit ce
laboratoire radio pour venir mesurer les
performances radio des équipements donc
donc là l'idée ici c'est on dispose
d'une antenne cornée donc cette antenne
cornée nous permet de mesurer tout ce
qui se passe dans la bande de fréquence
de 1 GHz à 18
GHz juste derrière cette antenne là on
retrouve un boîtier alors ce boîtier il
est unique en France ensuite les signaux
radio sont envoyés via un câble qui va à
l'extérieur de la cach se connecter sur
un récepteur de mesure qui va de 1 Hz à
40 GHz et c'est ce récepteur de mesure
qui nous permet justement de faire la
trace RF du
produit
une fois que le Produit est placé dans
la chambre de mesure on utilise un
logiciel de mesure qui a été réalisé par
la société Nexio et donc l'objectif
c'est que le produit les émissions du
produit qu'on voit en bleu ici reste
sous les courbes rouges qui sont les
limites définies par les
[Musique]
normes les avantages pour les
entreprises qui vont pouvoir bénéficier
de cette plateforme unique au niveau
européen c'est tout d'abord un délai
beaucoup plus court dans la conception
de leur produit ils vont également
gagner en délai sur le time to market la
mise sur le marché et bien évidemment
sur le coût du projet puisqu'ils vont
bénéficier sur un site unique et un
guichet unique de l'ensemble des
prestations nécessaires pour pouvoir
évaluer et tester leurs produits avant
la mise sur le marché on va avir tester
les produits connectés qui vont utiliser
les réseaux 5g et à terme les réseaux 6G
et donc pour les consommateurs ça sera
un bénéfice de pouvoir bénéficier de
produit s tester et vérifier on continue
à investir sur les les technologies de
demain
c'est-à-dire l'intelligence artificielle
et la cybersécurité et donc notre
prochain investissement qui est en cours
c'est le futur laboratoire d'évaluation
des systèmes d'intelligence artificielle
le lia immersion que nous allons
inaugurer en février